right now a lot of college kids are on
vacation for spring break
yeah yeah that's right Spring Break it's
the students chance to take a break from
the pressure of school and really just
cut loose go crazy cool all right well
thanks thanks for coming guys and hope
you're having a great spring break it's
the best spring break whoa yeah you know
what would make this Spring Break like a
million times better if our hero Conan
would do a shot with us no I can't do it
I'm on I'm on television I will not do a
shot with you guys I can't do you know
what else you can't do because you're on
television act like such a wuss
oh oh I'm not acting like a worse I just
move it by doing a shot with us all
right I'll do one shot bring me
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you all right
I apologize anyway we have a great show
tonight we're gonna have a terrific time
call it you're coding yeah you know what
else would be totally sick
if you made a bundt cake yeah yeah make
a delicious bundt cake for spring break
that makes no sense
why would I do that without hey Conan
guess which hand my your nuts are in
okay come on knock it off
neither cuz I don't think you got it all
right we'd be smelling a delicious bundt
cake right about I'm not making a bundt
cake that's ours Conan you are being a
total nerd it's spring break
just make the bundt cake
[Applause]
fine I'll make a bundt cake fine okay
I'm making a bundt cake I'm putting the
batter in the pan oh yo yo yo Kona just
some lemon in that [ __ ] all right here
we go hey and you're lucky too cuz
luckily I prepared one in advance right
out of the oven
oh that cake looks crazy moist cone into
the bundt cakes pretty boy enough really
okay are we done here guys are we done
we're almost done as soon as you nurse a
baby bird back to health for a lot City
yeah turn down for what huh nurse a baby
bird
I don't know I don't know the first
thing about taking care of a baby bird
bro come on he's so easy first you sack
up second you just feed it an eyedropper
of life giving that der until it's
healthy enough to return to the wild
brah move on unless you're too scared
cuz you're a virgin
for God's sake oh just give me the baby
bird for God's sake it's ridiculous okay
here we go alright ya break ever
I'm sorry none of this is classic Spring
Break stop what college you guys go to
we're homeschooled yeah oh we're making
it up as we go we're actually raised
Amish okay
[Applause]
you have a great trophy night from the
social network call me by our name in
the new movie final forged army hammers
here via Nick Swardson on the program
[Applause]
more show coming up we'll be right back
stick around everybody
[Applause]
you